let us discuss JOHN CARTER in space this
is a very interesting film to describe
because it's getting pretty panned by
the critics around tomato setting up
something like 46% or something like
that so it's not doing very well
and I can see why I can you know it's
technically it's not a good movie but
there's an audience out there for this
kind of film it's a kind of film that's
very if you're just looking for
something creative and just sort of
simple action but still a lot creativity
this is sort of that film but I can't
act like there's not a lot of problems
with it or a lot of things that don't
make sense or at times it's too
complicated at times it's too simple the
best way I can describe it is if you
like films like Star Gate or Tron Legacy
films that are pretty preposterous are
pretty stupid but they're kind of
creative and they're kind of just fun
dumb action even though it doesn't
always add up it's that kind of film now
with that said if you can't stand those
movies and you're constantly pointing
out the problems with the plot the
problems with this kind of story you've
seen a million times and stuff like that
you're gonna hate it you know you're not
gonna like it
the story is it's hard to describe
without sort of laughing at this is a
pretty silly story I'm not sure if it's
based on a book or a lot I should have
looked at that before I did this but it
sounds like it's based on a book like a
series of adventure boats or something
cuz it literally starts off I start
laughing at the opening cuz it starts
off within sale you know I you know Mars
is actually populated yes yes indeed and
there is a tribe known as the kopaka boo
and they live in the city helium is a
city called helium really could you
think of a better name every time
there's a we must get to helium it's
like you come on it's a fantasy they
call it something else that's way too
silly okay you know but there's all
these in the opening and a lot of parts
in the movie they're throwing a little
bit too much at you too fast it's sort
of like trying to tell this Lord of the
Rings store
in a couple minutes which I guess where
the rains tried to do also but somehow
that worked a little better and even
then I think they just in the first film
I think they just barely got away with
it but it's just a lot of names who
haven't heard of that live information
being thrown at you and you know and the
ancient tribe of the bald mr. cleans
come down and they had the ancient
weapon of the blue thingy and the guy
who really may be a bad guy may be a bad
guy we don't know yet they give him the
ultimate power and the guy smiles and
the world will change forever it's one
of those things where it's like they got
the right idea that just thrown a little
bit too much and then the film starts
again with this guy who's looking for
this medallion and then he dies and it's
handed out to the son okay so the movie
starring again and then the son is
reading the diary of this guy and the
movie is told through that diary okay so
starting again and then you see this guy
is you know he's in Virginia and they's
transported to Mars okay the story
started again it starts like five times
which is really odd uh and that's kind
of a problem like I said there there's a
few too many this needed one more
rewrite in my opinion and I think
whatever it was based on it was probably
trying to really grab that and really
try to stick to it because you know the
people out there they're like you know
you can't change your repoter not one
word you know those kind of people would
have a heart attack you know say people
go nuts about the change something in a
comic book movie or something so the
pride trying to please that crowd while
also making a good movie and maybe in
the book it works or in the original
story but if it is I really should
apologize but just as a movie um it
they're throwing a lot at you but then
it comes down to store those very basic
plot lines as well where it's like the
guy befriends the native Martians and
there's a big bad guy coming in to take
over the planet and wants to marry the
beautiful princess you know but she runs
away because she doesn't want to be
forced to marry and of course she comes
across the incredibly good-looking hero
and they're gonna form a row man
over what three days I mentioned this
was Disney so it's odd because at times
you had this really sort of fascinating
story like the character can actually it
takes him a while to get used to how to
walk because his molecular structure on
this planet I forget what the reason is
why they can breathe you know but is
different so he could gravity's a little
lighter for him so he can actually leap
really far it has to be very careful
when he walks you know that kind of
stuff is fun on top of that the people
he the Martians are the oh no they're
these four armed people he comes across
these green creatures which look pretty
good they sort of look like Davy Jones
in that you can tell they're CG but you
know what it almost looks like they're
there it's actually they put a lot of
effort into it and you kind of buy it uh
anything with those people was great
because they create this culture they
create these really likable characters
and you really want to get to know him
more and you're really sort of siding
with them and then stuff like that and
I'm and the design of them is great too
it's just this great design they have
these horns that come down the side and
they have these four arms that it looks
like you know it's not like they use two
arms and the are two arms are dead it's
like they really do use all four um and
that stuff's all wonderful and I really
got into that stuff and then that times
when they would get into the more
complicated stuff like the history of
Mars or who said like these bald
creatures who are like trying to control
the universe or whatever like some of
their dialogue is kind of fascinating
and stuff you know some of it almost
sort of leaned towards that wow this is
like kind of good sci-fi and all this
sort of like dune or something like that
like these are very interested
interesting Walt well-thought-out the
stories and characters and stuff but
then they either throw too much of that
at you too much information or it goes
down to a story that's way too basic way
too much of a formula like I said you
know the princess being forced to marry
and the hero you know people be framed
than natives of course he's gonna you
know like they don't get along at first
but he's got to befriend them or
befriending the one or two people in
that tribe you know and stuff like that
um
but then there's other stuff like they
have this dog that's really creative I
love the design of this thing it's
really cute and it has this cool thing
where it can run really fast and that
makes for a lot of good action scenes
after the action scenes are a lot of fun
in this movie too um but again it's sort
of a mishmash because like the best
action scene in the movie there's a
scene where where he's staying behind
he's sending you know the princess and
whoever off and he's gonna stay behind
and fight the green people and it's this
really cool action scene but it's being
played like with this emotional
backstory with his wife and child and
stop and it's like no come on cool
action music give us the all that stuff
so it's it's definitely sort of this
mishmash mess you know I'm not gonna say
it's not and you know as storytelling
goes and characters and stuff like that
is this good you know in terms of the
patterns we see and you know we might
evolve with story and character probably
not uh but it reminds me very much of
those old Disney films that I I kind of
like I don't love but I like them okay
you know sort of like that three
musketeers a Disney movie or The
Rocketeer or something like that there's
sort of these we get down to it there
are these very basic adventure stories
and you can follow it enough it does get
complicated but you can just catch on to
what they're talking about you can get
the essential story because this is a
story we've seen a million times again
um so I'm very very split on it I'm glad
I saw it I'm glad I saw it on the big
screen I did see it in 3d 3ds okay it's
a lot of good 3d movies uh good looking
3d movies come out that venture is in 3d
actually looked pretty good instead of
it the 3d I think he's getting a little
better but three keen this one's just
okay that was that badge is okay um so
like I said I think for this kind of
film the people that would like it if
you're really looking for a sort of a a
simple bug creative adventure story that
you're you're just sort of looking to be
somewhat invested but you're not really
gonna question it that much you're just
sort of going to see some fun action and
some creativity you'll like it fine if
you're looking for like a really good
film something's going to
challenge you and you know really make
you think and say wow this movies doing
new things it's not doing much the only
new stuff I would say a lot of the
designs are praying eat and kind of new
and likes I think the stuff that the
green people is kind of cool is we've
seen before but I really like these
characters I like what they do with
these characters so there's some new
ideas but in terms of like the story
when it comes down to you've seen it a
million times and there's a lot of stuff
you can point out that either doesn't
make sense or isn't explained well so
for me I'm glad I saw it I'm glad I went
to see it even though I'm not you know
it doesn't fully work um
but yeah I think you can sort of get a
general idea about it like I say if you
saw Stargate or try and legacy or like
some of the old Disney adventure films
like three musketeers in Rocketeer or
something like that it's along those
lines it doesn't make much sense you
know but it has sort of the very basic
action-adventure stuff if you're done
with that stuff you want to see
something new you really want to be
challenged you're not gonna find it here
there's way too much to complain about
so hopefully that gives you an idea what
kind of film this is a whether or not do
you want to go see it so that's about it
now talk to you later